le temps passe vite à la ferme entre les
traites matin et soir christian jutra
prend soin de ses 90 bêtes de
l'entreprise et ses champs
comme chaque année les beaux jours
arrivent en même temps que le boulot
supplémentaire on finira premier cours
pour préciser et finir les arrosages
après
c'est sans parler de son bétail qui a
besoin de soins quotidiens
alors quand peut-il penser prendre des
vacances moi le favori c'est quoi ce
sont des vacances
chose certaine de longues vacances qui
ne sont pas envisageables
mais christian se fait un devoir de
prendre du temps d'arrêt on recule
on message aux sorcières on reconnaît à
aucun aucun phénomène et puis j'ai
instauré ça j'ai commencé avec trois
jours m'ont pas ils étaient pas frayer
avec ça des fois juste lâché un peu ça
nous permet de le preneur product
d'ivoire à
sa conjointe en sait quelque chose
éducatrice spécialisée et l'oeuvre comme
ressource d'être dans milieu agricole
l'enjeu de la santé mentale est de moins
en moins tabou mais les besoins restent
grands si on veut que nos animaux puis
notre métier aedian pour commencer par
nous le propriétaire allait bien et nous
l'agriculteur allait bien et après tout
va découvrir accents peu ce qu'on essaie
de faire le centre d'études sur les
coûts de production en agriculture
estime que dans le domaine de la
production animale les agriculteurs
travaillent environ 3000 heures par
année c'est en moyenne 60 heures par
semaine c'est une bonne charge de
travail effectives ensemble observé là
pour les plus jeunes agriculteurs un
souci plus gré
l'upm remarque aussi un changement de
culture
défensivement c'est plus valorisé d'une
meilleure conciliation
production vue familial vous dire et
puis on sent d'ailleurs dans le
transfert d'entreprise malgré des
avancées la détresse psychologique reste
présente le taux de suicide est plus
élevé dans le secteur agricole que dans
le reste de la société et ça touche les
hommes comme les femmes dans toutes les
positions
toutes les régions berne et radio canada
montréal